hello
white people black people hispanic
people
gay people straight people bisexual
people
people with limps people with lazy eyes
bald people people with full heads of
hair
people that sit up straight people that
have hunchbacks
all sorts of people i know you're here i
know you're watching
i know that you know that i'm dave rubin
and this is the reuben report direct
message
for february 23rd 2021
and we've got a nice collection of
stories for you and i'm going to get
right to it today
quick reminder of course click that
subscribe button if you're watching on
youtube and that little notification
bell so that you have a
small chance of seeing our videos and uh
reminder
it ends at the end of this week but
right now blaze tv is offering 30
off uh their yearly package it ends on
friday night february 26th
you can go to blazetv.com and get 30
bucks off
for the year oh and before we do
anything else
let's talk about wine real quick i'm a
man who enjoys
the red wine i've got a bottle of it
right here uh guys next time you grill
up a couple steaks
pop open a bottle of extreme altitude
malbec wine right here all right it
comes from these remote vineyards in
argentina
argentina located up at around 9000 feet
when these vintners aren't making wine
they're herding cattle so they know meat
they know barbecue and that's what these
malbecs are for
as soon as you open the bottle you're
going to experience delicious notes of
blackberry leather smoke
and a little dark cherry you're also
going to get less sugar
less chemicals and less additives and 10
times more
resveratrol which is a powerful
longevity booster
and uh i've been busting out the malbec
you guys know i like my steaks
and uh it's dark and it's rich and it's
good the guys over at
freethinkerwine.com just got a special
shipment of these wines in they've got
one
malbec from the third highest vineyard
in the world at 8
950 feet visit freethinkerwine.com and
you'll get 50
off the wine and 50 off shipping this is
just a small batch and it's going to go
fast
just visit freethinkerwine.com that's
freethinkerwine.com
and now back to me all right first off
clyde is barking like crazy right now
i don't know if people can hear it but
should we maybe go put them in a cage or
like we should treat them like a migrant
children and put them in a cage now you
think we should do something i'm not
sure what we have to do
who knows what's going on all right uh
let's talk about vaccines because uh the
infallible fouchy
as i like to call him has said many
things about
vaccines he has said many things about
masks
he of course has for the last year
been in charge of our covid
plan and sometimes he liked trump
sometimes he didn't like trump now he
seems to
like biden but every few weeks seems to
come up with a whole new
plan of what we're going to do or when
we'll return to quote
normality as he talked about yesterday
we played that clip with
him and dana bash from cnn but this clip
is going viral right now and i think
it's
worth watching because it's a cause for
alarm if you ever think we're going to
get back to anything close to
normality let's take a look so there
were things even if you're vaccinated
that you're not going to be able to do
in society for example
indoor dining theaters places where
people congregate
that's because of the safety of society
you yourself
what you can do when you are together
with another
person we are looking at that and we're
going to try and find out very quickly
what recommendations could be made about
what people can do
what what after the vaccine
you're gonna still have to wear masks
you're gonna still have to social
distance you're still gonna they're
gonna come up
with a plan related to who you see and
where you see them i mean this is
seriously dangerous stuff and of course
dot dot dot because of the safety of
society that that sounds a little bit
like palpatine remember remember
palpatine
for a safe and secure society
and then that didn't work out for the
rebels or any or anyone else all right
uh we got some problems on our hands
because not only are we watching our
institutions collapse i would say at
this point
but how can anyone trust anything right
like
how are they giving us any path to
feeling like we are ever going to return
not to normality as faux calls it
but just to something remotely sembling
remotely a remote semblance let's say
of a free society that that would be
nice to me
but after you get vaccine now let's
let's just do the math here again and
i'm not a mathematician so i want you
guys to check this out
at home but the the covet virus has
about a 99
recovery rate and we know that the
people who die have several
co-morbidities usually diabetes
or they're overweight or have some other
disease now we know that that is not to
say young people don't get sick
again i have several people that i know
that have gotten sick they've all
recovered
but we know that the people who actually
die are elderly people who are sick
with other comorbidities okay now 99 of
people
uh survive and now we've got these three
vaccines which people are starting to
get they've been getting them for
now what two months almost uh and you're
taking two portions right my parents
already took their first portion they're
gonna take their second portion next
week
and then the vaccine is supposed to be
there's three of them but
basically uh 95 effective so we have a
disease that
99 of people i'm writing it down 99
of people survive and now we've got a
vaccine that'll work for 95 percent of
people
why could we not go back to things let
me just read the quote again there are
things
even if you're vaccinated that you're
not going to be able to do in society
for example indoor dining theaters
places where people congregate that's
because of the safety of
society you yourself what you can do
when you are together with another
person we are looking at that
and we are going to try to find very
quickly what recommendations could be
made about what people can do
what do you mean so now they're suddenly
telling us if i'm understanding this
correctly
infallible fouchy what you're suddenly
telling us
two weeks to flatten the curve was a
year ago wear masks don't wear masks two
masks three masks wrap your head in
saran wrap
and now after the vaccine after the
vaccine
we also uh are not going to be able to
do certain things in society
like indoor dining theaters peop
places where people congregate no more
church no more temple that's not a thing
anymore we're not going to be doing that
anymore
these are not good people that are in
charge of us i'm sorry i
i believe that fauci at one time in his
career probably was a was a good decent
man
and i know he's done some things in the
past and he's helped with
a lot of aids research and a whole bunch
of other stuff and i i won't sit here
and tell you that his
his motives are not good i don't know
what his motives are
this is this is no longer tolerable this
is truly no longer tolerable if you want
to live free
what in god's name are these people
talking about
after the vaccine they're soon going to
give us very quickly
they're going to give us recommendations
about what we can do in our private
homes
this is dangerous stuff i i just don't
even know what to say at this point like
either you get it or you don't
like maybe you've been in a coma for a
while
uh which a coma probably has a worse
recovery rate than
than kovid but maybe you've been in a
coma maybe you haven't been paying
attention
but the the goal posts keep moving
the goal posts keep moving we were told
biden when he was running you know
trump is an idiot he's mismanaged covid
i'm gonna keep vouching around we're
gonna wrap this thing up real quick then
the second biden becomes president
oh we're gonna have a cold winter a dark
winter scary things are coming
what is happening here people you gotta
make some decisions for yourself you
know i talked yesterday about
being in florida a state that did not
lock down that basically
is open and people are making decisions
for themselves that is the only way we
are going to get out of this
and also even let's just let's just say
the virus was far more risky and the and
the mortality rates were far
worse and it was killing a lot of young
people well we're still a year
later at what point can we say the
government either doesn't know what
they're doing that these
experts don't know what they're doing or
that whatever precautions they're taking
are far worse we know about suicide
rates with young people we know that
alcohol
rates have been going up alcoholism you
know i was even thinking about it
yesterday i'm by no means an alcoholic
you guys know i do like my red wine but
i've probably drank more
in this past year than ever before
because you're home you're just kind of
home more and it's like
we can't do things you can't see friends
whatever you're gonna do
i try to drink a lot of water when i'm
doing it and then i sit in the sauna in
the morning when i can
to sweat it out but the point is when
are we gonna say
enough enough of this that whatever you
guys are telling us you move the goal
post you change what you're saying
you tell us about masks you tell us
about lockdowns we were wearing gloves
at supermarkets
all of these things and then you know
eventually okay then then they'll
slightly open up and then they'll tell
us about the
the brazilian variant and the strain
from argentina and all of these other
strange things and then they'll open up
for a little bit and then three years
from now they'll tell us that we need
climate lockdowns and you can't get in
your car anymore and everything else
like that
it is just so obvious to me i don't
think that's a conspiracy theory to say
these things
we are watching a certain set of ideas
like i'm not saying it's a cadre and a
cabal
of eight people making these decisions
but we're watching
like an authoritarian horrible set of
ideas
just see how much it can push us how
much it can manipulate us and everything
else
none of this makes sense anymore i'm
sorry fauci you don't make sense anymore
you you this none of this makes sense
the cdc i saw a video on twitter today
the cdc was telling people not to wear
masks
back in last march back in april unless
you're uh
you know a medical professional you
shouldn't do it and it's not going to
help
and now it's like everyone wear them
forever and then we'll give you more
recommendations
you just hang tight sheep hang tight
sheep we'll let you know
when you can see your brother again okay
this is this is just absolute
ridiculousness i i don't know
where where are the mature people in
society i suspect all the mature people
are
selecting out of society i think a lot
of people are moving to the limestone
hills of montana is that such a place
seems like a place the limestone hills
of somewhere where do they have
limestone hills remember in the movie uh
deep impact
morgan freeman was the president and
they knew that the asteroids were going
to hit
and there was going to be massive
flooding so they built
uh something in the limestone hills of
somewhere they built like the the ark i
think is what they called it and that's
where they were going to have like three
million people live the limestone hills
of somewhere
people are the point is people are just
going to start checking out of society
if all society can do is give us experts
who have no idea what they're talking
about i'm sorry
you know what let me put it this way
fauci if you want to come on the show i
will gladly talk to you at one point
i think we had made contact you know he
was doing he was doing interviews with
everybody now it seems like he only goes
on cnn
all the time i will gladly interview
fauci i just don't know how can i
believe this anymore how can i believe
because of the safety of society
you're gonna tell us what to do for
example indoor dining theater
places where people congregate should we
never see people again should we all sit
in our rooms alone for now on
and just do everything by zoom is that
what you want is that what you want
maybe it is what they want and then
they'll decide who can be on zoom and
who can be online
and then before you know it before you
know it it's over
because that's that's what they're
giving us really banana stuff guys
uh let me talk to you for a second about
patriot mobile because i've got some
great news to share
about my friends over at patriot mobile
they just expanded their coverage
dramatically which will make it even
easier for more americans to switch
to the wireless company that shares
their values leaving big name carriers
who charge you way too much behind
i'm proud to partner with patriot mobile
because they are mobilizing freedom
at a time when it seems like everyone
else is threatening to silence us
i mean hell of a segway to the last
story and as america's only christian
conservative wireless provider they are
donating a portion of every dollar
earned to support organizations fighting
for religious freedom
first and second amendment rights
sanctity of life and the needs of
veterans plus you can switch with
confidence
because they use the same network as the
larger providers but charge much less
switching is easy keep your phone number
bring your own phone or buy a new one
build your own bundle with multi-line
discounts and save even more just go to
patreonmobile.com
reuben or call their us based customer
service at 972 patriot
that's 972 patriot veterans and first
responders save even more
this month get a free premiere
activation where they set up the phone
for you and a special gift
with the offer code ruben go to
patreonmobile.comruben
that's patreonmobile.comruben or patriot
and now back to me all right if if you
don't
think that whatever is going on with
fauci and whatever's going on with these
rules
is a little crazy and we're not really
getting the truth
and the people that are the experts and
supposedly
governing over us if you don't think
that they're not doing a great job well
right now we've got these hearings
happening on
capitol hill although a lot of it's
being done by skype and zoom and
everything else
for the attorney general pick uh of
merrick garland so they have the you
know in effect congress has to decide if
he is going
uh to be the next attorney general or
not so they're asking him a lot of
questions and there's been a whole bunch
of clips
going viral and i have to say i i have
not been
impressed with this guy he's kind of
fumbly and mumbly
it's a little unclear what he's saying
he doesn't get to the point he's he's
just not
been great but i don't care about any of
that and i suspect i suspect he's
probably
a decent person however some of his
answers have
just been unbelievably horrible
this is video from nbc news and
he was asked about attacking federal
property
and is that terrorism is that domestic
terrorism
let's take a look let me ask you about
uh
assaults on federal property in places
other than washington dc portland for
instance seattle do you regard assaults
on federal courthouses or other federal
property is acts of domestic
extremism domestic terrorism well
senator my own definition which is about
the same as the statutory definition
is the use of violence or threats of
violence
and attempt to disrupt democratic
processes
so an attack on a
courthouse while in operation trying to
prevent
judges from actually deciding cases that
plainly is
um domestic uh um uh uh extremism
um um um uh domestic
uh terrorism um an attack simply on a
government property at night
or any other kind of circumstances is a
clear crime
and a serious one and should be punished
i don't mean i don't know enough
about the facts of the example you're
talking about but that's where i draw
the line one
one is both are uh criminal um
but one is uh a core attack on our
democratic institutions
did you catch what he just did right
there so that was josh howley asking the
questions right there and
in effect what merrick garland said is
that if you attack a federal building
during the day when people are there
then i guess that's kind of terrorism
but if you attack the building at night
when people aren't there maybe that's
just criminal that's not terrorism
the implication being that you could go
to your federal courthouse
and as long as you blow it up at night
that you're not a terrorist that just
has to be during the day now
sorry to the uh the night watchmen there
or the
uh the evening janitor because they're
gonna get blown up in a terrorist attack
by the way don't blow up federal
buildings political violence is never
okay i'm fully willing to say that
unlike
so many people these days that have no
problem with blm and anti-violence
federal uh attacking attack well i'll go
even further
you're not allowed to attack people
violently
you're not allowed to attack buildings
and property violently
can't do that in a civil society i know
that's edgy
i know that's out there but that's my
personal belief but this
odd distinction that he's making that
somehow
depending on the time of day that you
attack a federal building
and who might be there at that time of
day because that's obviously the next
extension really of what he's saying
that that will decide whether
something's a terrorist attack or not
and what really so what is this really
about what is this really about does
does merrick garland honestly believe
that depending on the time of day if you
attack a building
that in one case it's terrorism or one
case it's not terrorism the answer to
that is obviously no i i don't think
there's any way he actually believed
that what he's trying to do here is an
extremely
dangerous slippery slope which is he's
trying to excuse antifa violence we know
that antivirus was attacking
the portland courthouse we know they've
attacked federal buildings in seattle we
know that they've attacked all sorts of
uh governmental and private property all
over the place by the way i don't even
know that i would make a distinction if
you just burn
down a target or you burn down a pep
boys which antifa has done i'm not even
sure that that's act is that worse or
better than burning down
a governmental building i think there's
a philosophical debate there like just
because you burned down
private property it's not the government
that that is somehow better than burning
down the federal thing but putting that
philosophical issue behind
uh this is seriously dangerous because
what he's saying is there's some excuse
there's some delineation between when
antifa does things he didn't say antifa
specifically
but that's obviously what he's talking
about right it's there's some
distinction between when they do that
kind of stuff
and when other people do other things
and this is seriously dangerous by the
way there was another
moment in that hearing which we were
going to play we decided not to
where he's asked about men
men biological men who transition
to female who then play in female sports
and if that's okay
and he basically can't answer that
question sort of said something like i
haven't thought about it enough
something like that
it's like again are these supposed to be
the experts
who should be in charge of our health in
terms of fouchy and in charge of our
laws in terms of merrick garland being
the attorney general
man we're in trouble we're in a lot of
trouble people
but if you don't think we're in trouble
i got even more trouble this is an
alarming show today
uh congressional democrats are promoting
the idea that
fox news and oan and newsmax who all
you're not going to believe this they
all happen to be right-leaning
news networks that they should all be
censored so this is
from the paper formerly known as the new
york times
members of the house energy and commerce
committee
sent a letter on monday to comcast a t
spectrum dish verizon cox
and altus asking about their role in the
spread of dangerous
misinformation the committee members
also sent the letter to roku
amazon apple google hulu digital
companies that distribute
cable programming the scrutiny of cable
providers took on new
urgency after supporters of former
president donald j
trump who repeatedly promoted the debunk
claim that the election was rigged
stormed the capital on january
6. so all right come back to me for a
sec so before we get to the
to the quotes i've got some quotes from
the democratic politicians although i
would say they're activists more than
politicians at this point
do you see what's going on here so now
let me just link all these stories
together we've got
medical people in charge of us
constantly moving the goal posts and now
they're going to
get back to us as to when we can get
together with people okay that's one
thing
we've got a potential incoming attorney
general who's in charge of the law
who can't decide or in effect
has decided that depending on what time
you blow up the federal building
well that'll uh you know that'll depend
on what uh crime and punishment it is
and now
we have a group of democratic
politicians trying to basically take out
the opposition
meaning that oan it doesn't matter this
is actually completely irrelevant to my
feelings about any of these networks now
obviously
i go on fox a lot they let me go on they
never censor anything i say
i go on live and that's it okay that
that's my experience with fox
and by the way i never get invited by
cnn
i never get invited by msnbc i did have
a
new york times uh a new york times
bestseller
i sold a book and it was a new york
times bestseller for some reason fox put
me on
why and it was all about defending
liberalism why didn't cnn put me on why
didn't msnbc put me on
um that's a bit of a sidebar but the
point is they want the opposition taken
out what these democratic politicians
are saying is
oh there's information out there on
these scary right
wing networks and we don't want half the
populous
actually knowing things that we don't
want them to know
so not only are we going to try to get
them kicked off the cable carriers right
that's the comcast the ats
but we're also going to talk to roku
we're also going to talk to apple tv
and google play and all of the other
places that you guys can get streaming
things
and is it really because they don't want
people to
uh be confused by misinformation or do
they really mean counter information
what information would it be would be
okay that these people would say hey
that's all right it's just a different
opinion they've decided that half of us
are racist
and why would you allow racists to be on
networks or why would you allow them to
have apps or get their information out
in any way so if you think this is just
about
them coming up for fox news or newsmax i
think you got another thing coming
we got a quote here from two democratic
representatives
anna ashu and jerry mcinerney
to our knowledge the cable satellite and
over-the-top companies that disseminate
these media outlets to american viewers
have done nothing
in response to the misinformation aired
by these outlets
scary that's scary stuff we've also got
a quote from house
energy and from the house energy and
commerce committee letter this is the
letter that they actually
uh sent to the carriers are you planning
to continue carrying fox news
oann and newsmax on your platform
both now and beyond the renewal date if
so why do you see people
that this is the government trying to
infringe
on free speech this is what we would
call the outsourcing
of tyranny they're saying oh we can't
silence people because of that gosh darn
pesky first amendment
so we're going to try to put pressure on
private companies
to eliminate the voices that we don't
want this by the way is very similar
to you may remember some of the hearings
about big tech and one of the things
that aoc was trying to do
was really pressure really scare mark
zuckerberg at facebook and jack dorsey
at twitter
and some of the other big tech people to
basically say if you
don't deal with misinformation and what
she means by misinformation is stuff
that i don't like
that we will do something about it
because she knows as the government
can't step in
and stop your speech because the first
amendment at least they can't do it yet
that she would try to outsource the
tyranny make sure that oh the companies
will do it
so it's not just that they want fox and
newsmak booted
but they also want to then push big tech
to get rid of you
this is seriously dangerous stuff man
i've given you three scary scary stories
and i'm ending it
with one that's so stupid that it's it's
beyond scary this one should be in
normal times this one would be scary now
it's just like patently absurd and if
you've ever
seen anything that sums up everything
happening in the world right now well
here is a cartoon
network uh promo because they're they're
promoting
anti-racism and wait for it because
anti-racism is
[Music]
join our racism doesn't matter if you're
white or black
or purple what the whoa whoa whoa
hold up a minute here uh who wrote this
i think it kind of does matter that i'm
purple i mean i'm purple because i'm
literally an
alien well i'm not an alien but it
definitely matters to me that i'm black
yeah it makes a difference then i'm
white i know the two of us get treated
very differently i just think it's
messed up to compare me being an
alien to you two being different races
you're both human you're
you're totally biologically the same
adding purple people into a lesson about
human racism makes
no sense yeah that is pretty weird i
think people like the black white or
purple thing
because adding a fantasy race in there
helps distract from the actual races and
black people have to deal with
right my experience with anti-black
racism is really specific
other people of color experience other
forms of racism too
but you won't see any of that if you
don't see color dude
so this entire public service
announcement could be a ploy to avoid
talking about racism all together
hey uh can we get a rewrite where we
appreciate each other without erasing
what makes each of us different
okay but it's gonna add a couple hours
to the shoot i can make yours open
uh you were rolling just now weren't you
can't we just slap some graphics on this
and call it a day
that is some propaganda horseshit
[ __ ] on a stick oh my god this is
literally what cartoon network is
promoting to children
and think about how many parents just
let their kid go watch
cartoon network you think you're
watching reruns or ren and stimpy or
whatever the hell's on cartoon network i
have no idea anymore i used to
get stoned and watch ren and stimpy on
cartoon network when i was about 22.
i don't i don't know what they're doing
now except for that craptastic stuff i
mean
do you see what they're doing there
they're making everything about race
in the name of non-racism and that
little black girl telling you how much
racism she experiences she's a
fictitious black girl by the way
and also why was they had a white
director there i mean let's get that guy
fired right there's that
guy he's just sitting there white
directing he shouldn't be doing that
could they not find
a black director i mean the whole thing
is such nonsense and the way they play
it and then try
to flip it like they're the good guys
it's just gross if i had a bucket to
vomit in i would do it right now
and i suspect some of you are vomiting
at home cartoon network i don't like you
so to recap today's show uh fauci the
infallible fouchy
no good no good this isn't working
anymore and a lot of people are pissed
not good but you can't do violence
people remember no violence
obviously uh what was the second story
jesus christ there's a lot of stuff then
uh
merrick garland might be the attorney
general and he'll decide whether blowing
up a federal building
is terrorism or not it'll depend on the
situation don't upset him about that
the democrats are trying to remove any
uh
voices of of counter programming
from cable and from the apps that's
wonderful and cartoon network is
brainwashing your children
i'm dave rubin this was the reuben
report direct message
for february i think 23rd 2021 there's a
lot going on in the world guys
we're in it together man we're in it
together craziness really just craziness
but let's keep fighting that that's all
we can do
keep fighting keep building i have
nothing better to do than save the world
i assume you don't either so let's just
keep going
thanks for watching everybody have a
great day